hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar better data fewer mice
micro CT imaging breathes new life into
your lung research I am Judy O'Rourke of
laberd's and I'll be moderating this
session today's educational web seminar
is presented by lab routes the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning it's brought to you by
PerkinElmer PerkinElmer is a global
leader committed to innovating for a
healthier world their innovative
detection imaging informatics and
service capabilities combined with deep
market knowledge and expertise help
customers gain earlier more accurate
insights to improve lives and the world
around us for more information about our
sponsor please visit PerkinElmer com
let's get started you can post questions
to the speakers during the presentation
while they're fresh in your mind to do
so simply type them into the drop down
box located on the far left of your
screen labeled ask a question and click
on the send button questions will be
answered after the presentation to
enlarge the slide window click on the
arrows at the top right hand corner of
the presentation window
if you experience technical problems
seeing or hearing the presentation just
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window or
report your problem by typing it into
the answer a question box located on the
far left of your screen this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I now
present today's speakers dr. Christian
Doolin dr. Sasha Belen cough and dr.
Francesca Rosetti
dr. Doo lien studied technical physics
at the friedrich schiller university ena
and finished his thesis based on
extracting the 3d skull out of MRI
datasets in 2001 in 2004 he moved to the
Institute for diagnostic and
interventional radiology at the
university medical center good ingen UMG
where he was responsible for technical
aspects of preclinical imaging he
finished his PhD on novel imaging
strategies for preclinical lung research
in 2015 during this time he was part of
several European projects one of which
was the public-private partnership for
asthma genomics and imaging his work
there is also predominantly dedicated to
lung imaging dr. Dylan has founded his
own sub group at the UM G focused on
x-ray based preclinical imaging
techniques his complete bio is found on
the lab routes website dr. Bellin Coggs
and applications scientist at
PerkinElmer sasha has been working in
the field of preclinical imaging for
more than ten years in his current role
he is responsible for the development
and support of novel imaging
applications and approaches prior to
joining PerkinElmer he worked for Vision
Medical GE healthcare and AR T advanced
research technologies he received his
bachelor's science and Anatomy and
molecular biology and PhD in
experimental medicine at McGill
University Montreal Canada
dr. Rouge Shecky is a scientist focusing
on in vivo imaging in the pharmacology
department at
lazy pharmaco okichi in Parma Italy
after graduating
Francesca started in the laboratory of
anatomy at Hospital of Parma
investigating the role of pkc
and cancer after a period as a research
fellow at the Institute Marie Curie in
Paris studying the immune system and HIV
she joined the AZ company and started to
work with imaging techniques such as
bioluminescence fluorescence molecular
tomography and computed tomography
applied to preclinical animal models
during this time she completed her PhD
in experimental respiratory physio
pathology and functional Diagnostics for
images of the cardio pulmonary system
dr. Dylan dr. Bellin Cobb and dr.
resetti will now begin their
presentations
everybody's there my name is Christian
darlin I'm from the University Medical
Center getting in Germany and I like to
show you how the token and a quantum
micro CT imaging system can be used not
only to measure structural changes in
lung disease models but also to measure
lung function in mouse models and of of
course function is a very important
parameter because that's directly
related to the symptoms and patients so
we work with asthma models in mice and
we use an over albumin induced model and
depending on the schedule and on the
amount of over albumin be inject we can
could use different collector grades of
Civility so in the middle you can see in
upper panel control mouse and then you
see a mild asthmatic asthma model and
the severe asthmatic model and you see
that there is a large amount of influx
of immune cells and swelling of the
bonky we use the quantum FX in vivo city
from Turkey Nano which is a very
versatile machine and can measure very
fast with a low amount of radiation and
it also has a life model for positioning
the mouse that can be exploited to
record movies of the breathing mouse and
these are some frames of such a movie so
you can see that you see that a change
in the shape of the lamp during
inspiration and you also see that the
brightness in the lung area is modulated
by a different amount of air so what we
can do first is to analyze these
brightness and you see if we if there is
an inspiration event it gets brighter
and we can also easily analyze the
motion of the diaphragm
so under anesthesia the most of the time
the mouse is in expiration and there are
only few events of inspiration so if we
simply average all the timeframes then
we get the shape of the lung in
expiration and if we measure the
standard deviation over time the part
that moves the most they give the
highest values to what you see on the
right side is that we can easily measure
the traveling distance the distance of
the diaphragm in' and already these easy
measurements gives some very interesting
ways of quantification of lung function
and we use this in a study to analyze
mice that have recovered from asthma so
we measured demise before provoking an
asthma attack we measure them directly
after naphtha attack and we measured
them 121 days later on the left side you
see the asthmatic one mouth of the
asthmatic cool and on the right side you
see a control nose and what you can see
is that there's more motion in the
asthmatic mouse and you can also see by
divided our head that there's also
motion on the chest so the mouse tries
to compensate the loss of lung function
by using the intercostal muscles and by
quantification you see you see in the
center of the slide that after 120 days
the area of the land comes back to
normal also the position of the
diaphragm comes back to normal and and
also the risk of the lung comes comes
back to normal but there are still some
slight modifications and to really
quantify that we developed the most of
the sophisticated analysis screen which
I am about to show you now so
if you record all these movies and
measure the change of the brightness
over the land you get these function
which is displayed below and each peak
can be quantified and the parameters of
this quantification we use to
discriminate between healthy and
asthmatic animals you see in this slide
three curves the blue one is a control
mouse the red one is an asthmatic mouse
mouse and the green one is the mouse
after automatic Mouse after treatment
and what you can see is that the
automatic Mouse has a higher baseline
that's called air trapping so the air
cannot be exhaled during the exploration
phase completely the peaks are smaller
that's partially because we has less air
in the lamp and also because we has more
tissue due to the spelling and you also
see that the peak is more a symmetric so
there is a prolonged expiration phase
which is related to the reduction of
elastic recoil in asthma and you can
also see that you can use that for
quantification of therapy response
because the green curve of the treated
mouse this news looks more likely like
the control Mouse and there's even more
air inside so it's more a little bit of
overcompensation we compare that the
stick usually approach of whole-body
plethysmography and we found that our
measurement is even more sensitive than
that
we also did other comparison like the
poncho eval alveolar lavage so basically
we washed out cells from the lung and
counted them and what you can see from
the TRL of results is that there is not
much of a difference between the treated
mouse in the middle did the group of the
treated mice in the middle and asthmatic
mice in terms of using opiates and total
immune cells if you do in histology
analysis then you see there is partially
or even a successful different treatment
result so there is a difference between
the asthmatic and the treated mice in
terms of inflammation and if you use the
our lung function approach you see that
is there a partially successful
treatment so the summary of that is that
you need to have different without
targeting different yeah features of the
disease because if you focus of only one
of them then you will maybe miss judge
the success of your treatment so the
measuring of lung function is really
important
and the same we see again for these
recovered mice and you see that after
one 121 days all parametres have back to
the control coup which is represented by
the red line but one parameter not
that's the air trapping parameter in the
lower right corner of the graph so that
means that there's no signs of
inflammation anymore but there is still
a reduction of elastic recoil and that's
something we know from the patient but
we were never able to reproduce that in
in nice and we are never able to measure
that and now we can using the micro CT
for lung function measurement we can not
only do that and we can also do that in
vivo and that would be very nice tool to
focus on treatment for these Lakes ace
of asthma
we correlated these findings with a
synchrotron radiation micro CT which we
already have established to study
asthmatic mice and we found a very nice
correlation between the ratio of AD to
soft tissue in these ex vivo scans with
the air trapping parameter measured in
vivo and this this ratio between air and
soft tissue is related to our
preparations theme of the specimen so we
keep the lung in situ and we inflate the
lung with air the constant pressure and
interesting thing is that the former
automatic mice or the recovered mice
they have a higher air content than the
healthy mice which is kind of concur
introduces intuitive but it points to a
loss in elastic recoil of the lung so it
can be inflated more with the same
pressure and that correlates perfectly
with the in vivo measurement so we can
validate the our in vivo findings and
again we have for the first time a tool
to measure this reduction in lastik
recall there's a high sensitivity in
vivo using the poke another micro CT
system and we also found the reason for
this reduction in elastic recoil by
histological and analysis of the lungs
and the first staining in the upper hole
is a so-called mathematic home staining
and it stains fibers so we don't see a
difference in the amount of fibres which
is usually the case for strong mouse
models because they tend to develop
fibrosis so there is no fibrosis in our
asthma model the next staining in the
central is for I found smooth muscles
muscle actin so there is a significant
difference in that and the last one is
for elastic fibers and what we see is
they are still 120 days after the last
asthma attack there is a strong
reduction in
elastic fibers so our hypothesis is that
during the inflammation in the acute
phase the elastic fibers get destroyed
and we will never ever be recovered and
that probably also the reason why this
happens in patient and maybe we can find
the treatment to prevent elastic fibers
from being destroyed if software be used
for that that's open access so you can
look up the open access paper and you
find a link to the software one word to
the DOS so you would think a lung
function measurement based on x-rays is
maybe not a good idea because of the
radiation dose but we found out that we
can do these recordings with a very low
amount of radiation because that's a
statistic measurement and the dose has
not that much influence on this average
blackness over the whole area of the
lung Toby only used six mini gray of
those which is much less than you would
apply for standard in vivo city so
that's the reason why we believe we can
do that longitudinal would the times
without applying too much those
so in summary we use the PerkinElmer
quantum accuracy team for recording of
the movies of the breathing mouse we can
record up to 34 seconds with very low
dose and these movies can be used to
address lung function and can also be
used to derive parameters and these
parameters can be used to discriminate
at mammals from mouse models of
differents ability we can address
therapy response and we have for the
first time able to review persistent
loss and elastic recalls in life
recovered from asthma and there's a new
system the quantum GX that recalls even
faster so that will be even more
beneficial for this purpose
and now I'd like to end you over to the
next speaker
Sasha Belenko the introduce to how the
PerkinElmer quantum city can be used for
three-dimensional analysis of lungfish
thank you very much for your
introduction my presentation will be the
introduction to the quantum GX 2 neo
microscopy system from token Elmer this
system has a very small footprint
it doesn't need a dedicated room to be
operated the system can be used for
different animal models from mice rats
rabbits guinea pigs the system operates
with a two dimensional CMOS detector
which is called sometimes a flat-panel
detector over the large array and this
array can be used to acquire images with
high temporal resolution so the
framerate on the flat panel detector can
be achieved up to 117 trains per second
the system has a variable geometry and
can allow the user to change
magnification and achieve fields of view
from 18 to 86 millimeters
also the system can be used for really
high image acquisitions for example
images can be acquired in less than four
seconds also the resolution on the
system can be achieved down to two point
three microns a voxel size x-ray
detector and x-ray filters can be
operated with the filters so we allow to
use up to six different filters to
change the energy on the x-ray source
also the system has an integrated
graphical processing unit for image
reconstruction and images can be
reconstructed into volumes up to 1000
voxel or sub volume reconstructions with
8000 voxels and of course the system can
be used not only for anatomical imaging
but also for functional imaging for
example the system can be used with the
retrospective reconstructions for
cardiac and respiratory imaging so the
basic principle of the micro CT
operation is the same as on most of the
micro CT systems
this was the animation but
this animation is not working so the
imaging subject is placed in between the
x-ray source and the detector and then
the x-ray source and the detector they
rotate around the subject acquiring
multiple projection images and images
are acquired over 360 degree rotation
once all the projection images are
acquired they will be reconstructed
using the graphic processing unit and
the images can be displayed in
transverse coronal and sagittal
orientation the system as I mentioned
previously has a variable geometry which
will allow an operator to place a
subject near to the x-ray source to
achieve high magnification or to place a
limiting object away from the x-ray
source to acquire large fields of view
in this sense the system can be compared
with the microscope with multiple
objectives for example with low
magnification the user can get high
image field of view and with the high
minification the the user can get really
high magnification with a small field
and the size the system can be used for
various types of imaging applications
that would range from imaging trabecular
bone structures imaging cardiac imaging
respiratory activities measuring total
body fat and some of these applications
for example for imaging fat do not
require a high resolution but they do
require large fields of view and
contrary trabecular bone analysis will
not require imaging large fields of view
as the size of the trabecular structures
and the bones themselves quite small but
the resolution will be required at about
10 or maybe 15 micrometers so the system
should be able to get this resolution
for both trabecular analysis the high
resolution imaging and low resolution
imaging for a full body imaging one
should also notice that with the high
magnifications images will be acquired
over a longer period of time and the
such radiation to the animal will be
higher
of the various geometry we can also
image different species for example mice
rats guinea pigs and the system comes
with different bore covers so we have
bore covers for small animals we have
bore covers for sample imaging so and
with these bore covers we can also use
different animal bed as you can see the
system is equipped with the integrated
anesthesia unit so the animals can be
put on gas in the stiva for example iso
7 anesthesia and then can be imaged
inside the cabinet which is fully
shielded so the operator is not exposed
to ionizing radiation the system also
operates with the Micro Focus x-ray
source and it's quite important to have
a system equipped with Micro Focus x-ray
source if one needs to acquire images at
high spatial resolution for example if
the system doesn't have a micro focus
x-ray source if it's a regular x-ray
source that you can see from this image
that x-ray photons can be emitted from a
relatively large area and then you will
get such in fact as the number of
blurring and this penumbral blurring
effect will be great image quality and
such images may not be useful for
example for high resolution imaging of
trabecular structures the resolution of
the system can be verified using one of
those phantoms this is an example of a
bar pattern phantom from the company
called qrm this phantom has multiple
bars spaced at different distances so
you can see that you when you can zoom
in on a middle portion of the phantom
and if you can see that some of these
bars can be resolved so this is the
resolution that the system can achieve
so this is very useful to to check the
capability of the instrument and for the
quality control
I also mentioned that the system the
quantum gx2 system is equipped with a
flat panel detector and the flat panel
detector is a different type of the
x-ray so x-ray energy detector than CCD
based detector most of the commercial
available micro CT systems are equipped
with the CCD based detectors this is
relatively old technology and in order
to record the images on such systems
these systems employ image the
magnification approach where the image
from the large area sincerly to need to
be be magnified to be collected the
signal can be collected on the CCD
detector and during this magnification
process image quality can be degraded
also image intensity can be lost and
usually the micro city systems equipped
with the CCD base detector they would
require longer imaging times and as such
longer exposure of the animal to
analyzing radiation the advantage of the
x-ray detector based on the flat panel
technology is that there is no need for
image D magnification so the energy can
be more efficiently recorded and at
relatively short exposure times another
advantage of this type of the detector
is that the images can be rapidly read
from the data read from the detector for
example or the flat panel detector based
on the being used can read images from
50 to 100 times faster than the society
based detector so for example with large
pinning on the flat panel detector we
can record up to 117 images per second
and if you compare to the CCD based
detector see BCD BCD based detectors
usually record from 3 to 20 frames per
second so such temporal resolution may
not be sufficient to image for example
animals applications like cardiac
and I also mentioned that the system is
equipped with the retrospective gating
and why did its respective or any type
of gating is required is that when we
image small animals the heart is beating
the the lungs are also changing the
position and if no care is taking about
compensating for the movement of the
organs you will get the image similar to
this one so you can see that the borders
of the lung are blurred the
interventricular septum and the left and
right ventricles there also notes well
delineated so this is the kind of the
image that you will get if no care is
taking about the gating most of the
current approaches rely on the use of
the external monitoring equipment such
as EEG or respiratory triggers to record
the cardiac activity and to record
respiratory activity and this technique
requires the use of the electrodes
attached to the animal also attachment
of the some respiratory pad and of
course there is a need for the operator
to learn how to use these devices
sometimes the use of these devices can
be affected by electric noise sometimes
the electrodes can fall off so it takes
time to set up everything before you
start imaging the animal and sometimes
through throughput of such imaging
procedures significantly reduced with
the quantum gx2 systems we do not
require the user to use external
monitoring equipment although the
equipment can be used
we have ports where the wires and cables
can be put through the scanner so it's
not a problem but it's not mandatory to
use the sort of the equipment form
gating for cardiac and respiratory
gating everything that the user is
required to do is to place a small
region of interest all right so you can
see this outlined in yellow over the
region of the diaphragm
and the heart and then the software in
the background will record changes of
the intensity in this region of interest
and we'll figure out which frames belong
to which cardiac or respiratory cycle
for example large spikes shown on the
graph
they represent respiratory movements and
small spikes on the graph they represent
cardiac movements and the systolic and
systolic phases are on top and and
diastolic phases are below so the user
does not need to perform any of the
selection of these projections manually
the software the gating software group
of will perform projection sorting and
then the reconstruction automatically so
the process of image acquisition and
then image reconstruction is seamless
with no requirement for the user to
enter any kind of parameters this is an
example of the image which can be
acquired on the quantum gx2 system you
can see one of the project
projection the cross cross axle images
so you can see nice the elimination of
soft tissues bone tissues enhance blood
vessels the image analysis is used on
them but different techniques which rely
on intensity gating for example voxels
in the image of around minus 1000 hounds
of Units they are represented by air
voxels put the intensity levels above
1000 hounds of Units they represent bone
images if the tissue soft tissue has a
value of 0 Hounsfield units if lung has
a mixture of air and soft tissue the
values of in between 0 and minus 1000
Hounsfield units and if the contrast
agent is injected the amount of
enhancement in the blood vessels will be
proportional to the amount of iodine
injected to the animal and on average 1
milligram of iodine well we'll give you
enhancement values of approximately 30
Hounsfield units so then the image can
be plotted as a distributor histogram of
value so this is distribution of
different intensity values and you can
see that each compartment has its
signature for example air is on the left
and bone is on the right in between we
have origin so they they are represented
by nice distributions and if you place
different thresholds around these
distributions these organs can be
delineated their mean values can be
calculated standard deviations and also
volumes of the structures can be
calculated instead of performing
external reconstructions this is an
example on the left you can also perform
internal constructions and then you can
perform so-called virtual endoscopic
views so in this case no monitoring
devices needed to be placed inside the
animal so it's just the use of the same
projection images but slightly different
traction technique and then we can look
through different organs like blood
vessels we can take a look through the
airways and de-seed what is the type of
disease can be visible from the inside
some sort of the reconstructions can
also allow exploration of three these
can be airway threes this can be
vascular trees people can calculate the
number of branches vocations also the
tortuosity of some segments this is very
useful technique to look at abnormal
blood vessels so if one is interested to
perform such can calculate ins the
system with life animals can be also
used with external ventilators so many
people know that for example lung
diseases they are not homogeneous
diseases they're highly heterogeneous
and if one uses a ventilator the
ventilator will all only deliver for
example compliance resistance total
values global values of the lung but if
for some portions of the lung are
affected differently by the disease and
then if disease is not significantly
present present so overall value may not
be representative but with the help of
the micro CT and the ventilator you can
perform regional analysis of particular
lobes in the lung and you can calculate
lobular compliance values for example
resistance values here's an example of
the animal presented with emphysema
emphysema was induced by injection of
the ala stays to the animal and you can
see that the images can be reconstructed
at different phases here we have an
example of an inspiratory and expiratory
phases the image below was supposed to
show a 440 image so this is the changes
in
volume during the respiratory cycle
another condition which is commonly used
is the pulmonary fibrosis the fibrosis
in mice was induced by administration of
bleomycin bleomycin is an anti-cancer
drug and one of the side effects of this
drug is the development of pulmonary
fibrosis and you can see from the
example below after the PMI since was
injected the the the the right lung of
the animal was heavily affected by the
treatment but the left lung or spare so
you can see increase in lung attenuation
values in the right lung you can see the
involvement of pretty much all the lobes
even the cardiac lobe has disappeared
from the image because it was totally
non aerated there was a collapse in the
lobe and it's not visible and to
compensate for the function you can see
that the left lobe of the lung is
compensating with the hyper aeration and
this hyper aeration can be noticed on
the histogram which is presented on the
right hand side longitudinal imaging can
be also performed using the system this
is an example of lung tumor model so the
tumor was injected to the animal and the
tumor tumor cells were also expressing a
gene called luciferase in the presence
of the substrate luciferase luciferin
luciferase will produce light signal of
course light signal cannot be recorded
for the micro CT instrument and the
researchers can used one of the
PerkinElmer instruments called Ibis ibis
lumina or iris spectrum which will
record intensity of the in of the of the
light emitted by tumor cells and the
intensity of the light will be
proportional to the intensity of to the
number of the tumor cells so you can see
that on the upper side image
see normal healthy lung parenchyma which
is disappearing over time during - due
to the growth of the tumors in this this
model and also the images from the micro
CT and from the spectrum I the spectrum
system can be combined together to
perform image registration and the image
below represents combination of the
skeletal structures and also to the
color images of the tumor cells
themselves and what is interesting about
this image the graph on the right hand
side shows decrease in a healthy lung
parenchyma proportionally to the
increase in the tumor cell number and
you can see regardless of the number of
x-ray examinations x-ray imaging did not
affect the growth of the tumor and you
can know you know that the ionizing
radiation the radiation from x-ray
sources can stop tumors from growing so
the amount of radiation that we deliver
during quantum gx2 examination is very
low and is not capable of affecting at
these imaging protocols affecting the
growth of the tumor the image below
shows a different model it's a bone
metastases model in this case tumor
cells also Express luciferase which can
be imaged on the spectrum ibis system
and in this situation you can locate the
spread of the tumors to skeletal
structures and also the micro CT you can
examine the effect of the tumor cells on
bone growth or maybe to study the Ostia
lytic process induced by these tumor
cells and at the same time images of the
chest of the mouse or the rat also the
images of the heart and cardiac imaging
can be also performed with the Micra
city so for this you would need to
inject some contrast agents one of the
most commonly used contrast
iodine iodine has high electron density
and will cast a shadow on the x-ray
image and when this image is
reconstructed you can delineate
different heart chambers and main blood
vessels and micro CT the quantum gx2
microcytic system delivers images at
isotropic resolutions of the dimension
of the voxels in all XY and z directions
they are isotropic same in size and
heads the image quality that you can see
on this slide so you can see nice that
lineage of large and small blood vessels
you can see beautiful tribulation of the
left and right my cardio structures so
the images can be also used to calculate
changes in volume during the cardiac
cycle so the next example shows a mouse
model actual rat model with the
pulmonary hypertension so the control
animal is shown on the top panel and the
crisscross axial and Carano
cross-sections they show the heart at
different time points from end diastolic
to and systolic and again to end
diastolic phase that's only 10 images
which are shown but the images can be
acquired at really high temporal
resolution up to 117 stream frames per
second and this will allow multi-phase
reconstruction and analysis of all
cardiac chambers in time so we can
calculate the volumes of the left right
ventricle left and right atria and we
can also plot the values of the volumes
and we can also calculate the first
derivative and find what is the flow
values during the systolic and diastolic
function in the heart and the image
below shows the animal affected by the
disease pulmonary hypertension and we
can see all the signatures of this
disease for example hypertrophy of the
right ventricle
increase in the thickness of the
myocardial wall which can be also
measured with the quantum a gx2 system
and as well we can calculate some
functional parameters that represent a
systolic and diastolic function and with
this slide I want to conclude my
presentation and thank you very much for
your interest in the webinar and if you
have any questions please ask me the
questions during the the question and
answer session thank you very much
you
thank you for the kind introduction
in this webinar I will talk about the
invivo University as a powerful tool to
non-invasively monitor lung disease and
in particular lung fibrosis briefly I
will go through the human idea patek
pulmonary fibrosis IPS and how
preclinical animal models are needed to
recapitulate the disease improve
clinical trials second I represent data
obtained using quantum McCarthy t2 money
to our longitudinal antibodies and
response to treatment and in conclusion
I will summarize the benefits of using
micro CT technique for drug discovery
human iPS is a progressive disease that
results in a reversible loss of lung
function the median survival is around
three to five years an entire nib and
perf in pure fan Eden are the only two
drugs approved by FDA against IPF
so there is a user need to understand
more about IPS Papa biology and to find
out new biomarkers the use of new
imaging approaches such as micro CT
could increase a lot the travellish the
translational value of preclinical
trials
animal models play a crucial role in
drug discovery because of their utility
to make prediction to human clinical
outcome
we are deeply investigating different
animal models of lung fibrosis induce
the Bible amaizing
administration which is known to be one
of the most used prophylactic agents in
the literature
I will focused on results from the IT
model where blue myosin is given in to
attract early and from the pump model
where blue myosin is given systemically
by the in terms of an osmotic pump the
use of micro CT
as a fast and automatic tool gives the
possibility to overcome problems related
to the 2-dimensional astrology studies
even if it remains the gold standard
technique the micro CT offers with a 3d
view to study the complexity of the
pathology
high resolution city has gained a really
central role in the diagnosis of patient
with IPS where normal lung tissue is
replaced by new collagen deposition in
human patients are asked to be in total
lung capacity during the HR CT and their
frequency distribution is to ramp off of
an SI unit appear like that as you can
see in the left side in an alpha subject
in ITF patient on the contrary
and during disease progression the
typical with pattern called a shift of
the istagram towards zero with an
attenuation of the signal
but what happened in mice and in
preclinical studies mice are imaged
under gas anesthesia normally breathing
and this is why the reason this is the
reason why a control mouse has an SI
unit distribution with a mean around -
601 smiles are treated with bluem icing
and developed fibrosis because of the
loss of air they show a shift to the
right of the Easter bump distribution
for the quantitative assessment of the
lung parenchyma we applied an SI unit
clinical ranges published by Gaston Oni
and none resulted in the division of
normally aerated tissue segmented from -
902 - 550 and poorly rated region
segmented from - 502 - 104 unit and
these helps in determine different
degrees of aeration in a given tissue
fraction
the best should be to set up new ranges
to use in preclinical studies based on
data from every animal model so in the
next section I will illustrate some
experimental results we applied the
knowledge this method I explained before
to image obtained from blue mice in IT
model and we were able to follow
fibrosis progression in the same subject
over the time starting at baseline
at seven days thirteen up to 21 days
highlighting the capability of micro
City to visualize longitudinally the
progressive anatomical changes of the
land architecture
the left plot showed the quantification
of normally and poorly rated tissue as a
percentage on the total lung volume of
blue myosin treated mice in a time
course study the Ashcroft score obtained
by astrology was in agreement with
micro-ct findings showing a maximum peak
at 14 days an attempt to decrease at a
later time point
moreover to support micro CT data we
align the astrologist lies with the same
2d slice from CT scans a significantly
visible correlation has been found
between poorly rated tissues and the
position of fibrotic regions in
astrology calls lies a notably severe
fibrotic lesions classified with an
Ashcroft around five six up to eight
lead to a loss of signal detection in CT
images this is do you probably to Apache
distribution of fibrotic for Chi in lamb
parenchyma caused by blue myosin give in
to tackling to become this issue we
applied the same method of analysis to
images from blue mice in pump model
which has a less severe fibrosis but a
more uniform lesion distribution because
of a constant and systemic release of
demising for seven days we follow it
fibrosis progression from day seven when
the disease as well as stablished up to
28 days
notably the total um parenchyma is
completely detectable because of the
emotional distribution of the lesion
with a progressive attenuation of the
signal compared to the Saline the
quantification of poorly rated regions
at 28 days resulted in an increase up to
80% mice treated with the ante fibrotic
compounds new tedamy showed the
significantly degrees of poorly rated
region with an inhibition of 67% at the
higher dose of 60 milligrams per key
according to defining histology Ashford
score data showed similar results in
Tiger name showed to be effective in
reducing a shot with an addition of 39%
poorly rated region positively correlate
with actual score with an r-squared of
0.6 on over the experimental group
in 2017 80s guidelines the use of animal
models in preclinical studies for the
assessment of potential therapies again
pulmonary fibrosis has been published
the document highlights the importance
of practical aspect related to the
models such as the blue mice and routes
of delivery but also the pivotal role of
imaging techniques as a preclinical and
point therefore we decided to
investigate a third mirroring model of
lunch abilities in use by blue mice in
orally administered with a micro CT
longitudinal studies and pharmacological
response to the internal treatment are
ongoing in our lab
in conclusion I would like to summarize
some of the main advantages to use
micro-ct in preclinical research
micro-ct provides the searcher with
high-resolution 3d imaging information
and it can be used in longitudinal
studies to follow disease progression
and drug efficacy importantly the use of
clinical endpoints in preclinical
studies improve the translate ability of
results the micro CT advantage over
astrology is that it is a non-invasive
technique which are low researcher to
use less animal according to the free
our principle below you also can find
references link to publish data and
methodology
thank you all for your attention thank
you dr. julene dr. Bellin Calvin dr.
Shetty for your presentations a quick
reminder for our audience on how to
submit questions simply type them into
the drop down box located on the far
left of your presentation window labeled
ask a question and click on the send
button our speakers will address as many
questions as time permits first question
is for you
Francesca who what level of expertise is
needed to run the quantum and analyze
the data
we from PerkinElmer has a user-friendly
software which really has researcher to
perform imaging at a very high
resolution and I would say also that
that analysis is facilitated by the use
of an analysis software which gives the
possibility to use a semi automatic
segmentation tool to reconstruct 3d
images and also to have instagrams of an
three-unit distribution from different
tissues Thank You Christian this next
one looks like it for you what range of
radiation doses did the test subjects
typically receive the quantum micro CT
has different protocols and the protocol
that the lowest radiation dose is an
acquisition of 17 seconds and needed a
15 very gray which is really really no
and high resolution protocols need about
one gray which is still quite low for
animal scan
Thank You Sasha the next one is for you
what are the possibilities for using
prospective gating to adjust for the
breathing cycles of the test subjects
yes so prospective gating is not
possible on the quantum gx2 perspective
gating requires a triggering device that
will tell the instrument at respiratory
or cardiac phase the images should be
acquired so instead of this the quantum
is acquiring images in the retrospective
way and in this manner more information
about the breathing and cardiac cycle
can be acquired so the information from
retrospective gating has more value
thank you this next one is free to what
possibilities are there for using a
ventilator within the quantum imaging
experiments for example flex event yes
any ventilator including a flex event
ventilator
can be used with a quantum the images
will be acquired in a list mode and will
be gated threads respectively so all the
phases can be reconstructed and the
information from the Flex event can be
used to calculate pulmonary resistance
and pulmonary compliance
Thank You Christian this one is for you
could the same lung function measurement
be used in humans since we use a very
low dose for the lung function
measurement it would be applied in
humans and there are actually some
projects doing x-ray based Land
Foundation measurements in humans the
ultimate goal would be to do this will
CT so four dimensional imaging but yes
it can be done care thank you next one
for you too could the same approach be
used in other lung disease models like
fibrosis we are actually working on also
two lung function measurements in Cyprus
poses mouse models so yes it can be
excited any lung disease models that
change the lung function thank you we
have time for one more question it will
be for you sasha is dual-energy imaging
possible
quantum gx2 instrument has a variable
x-ray source and the voltage on the
generator can be changed as such the
energy can be adjusted also the quantum
gx2 instrument has various filters and
those filters can be also used to shape
the energy of the x-ray
again thank dr. du lien dr. Bellin cough
and dr. Shetty for their presentations
I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
will be addressed by the speakers via
the contact information you provided at
the time of registration we would like
to thank our sponsor PerkinElmer for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through June 2019 lab routes will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event until next
time goodbye